[Music]
every kid
knows what they want to be when they
grow up
when you're a kid you've got that candy
cane colored
anything is possible almost dream-like
view of the world
some kids want to be astronauts others
firefighters me
i was dramatic i wanted to be
an actress fantasized about it every day
never mind that i lacked the requisite
talent or parental support
this was my dream
and in that fantasy of fantasies that
deepest desire back when reality and
limits didn't exist
i was a supporting actress
a second fiddle to a lindsay lohan or a
hillary duff
i was never practicing any acceptance
speeches
deepest dreams tara was never up for any
awards
in my wildest most unattainable hopes
i was a sidekick
i've thought about this a lot in the
years since
i keep coming back to the sad
realization that as an ambitious child
with a huge imagination
i couldn't see myself as more than a
supporting player
in my own fantasy why couldn't i
well because the heroines in the tv
shows and movies that i watched growing
up weren't little brown girls
and without that model i couldn't even
dream of it
today i'm here to talk to you about how
deeply entertainment permeates our
culture
it impacts everything from what we think
about ourselves
to what we think about others and most
powerfully of all
it can actually impact what we do
it's an incredible tool and as a student
of public policy
i think it's time we used it for social
change
now i want to acknowledge that
entertainment has come a long way since
i was a kid
not just in terms of the representation
we see on screens
but also in terms of the kinds of
content we consume
for the purposes of today's talk i'm
defining entertainment as the content
that has
and continues to define the cultural
zeitgeist
film and television now first and
foremost
this entertainment impacts what we think
about ourselves
and what we believe we can achieve more
broadly the most prominent example of
this is known
as the scully effect let me take you
back
the year is 1996 and the x-files is one
of the most popular shows on television
if you didn't watch it it's kind of a
mystery criminal minds with aliens for
some reason it's a huge success
now the star of that show is jillian
anderson some of you may know her as
margaret thatcher on netflix's the crown
but back then she was dr dana scully
medical doctor hyper-competent scientist
and one of the first
prominent examples of a female scientist
on a major tv show
and guess what among women who watch the
show
dr scully's prominence can be directly
linked to an
increase in the desirability of stem
careers
a 43 percent increase to be exact
43 percent entertainment can
fundamentally impact what we believe we
can achieve
now how many women on boards have you
seen represented in entertainment
how many minority ceos it begs the
question
how much is entertainment reflecting the
sad realities of the world we live in
and how much is it perpetuating the
status quo
the scully effect shows us that
diversity and representation is
genuinely important not just because
what we see on screens
should reflect the world we live in but
because it can actually impact what we
believe we're capable of
second entertainment doesn't just impact
what we think about ourselves
it impacts what we think about others
now what we think about others is
directly tied to our empathy for others
and this is something progressive
politicians are very familiar with
they're trying to convince voters to
care about people that they might not
have a lot in common with
someone for example like an undocumented
immigrant
but politicians are failing to build
this empathy in the 30-second sound
bites they have our attention for
and even when we are listening our trust
in politicians is at a historic low
so if not from politicians where
can this empathy come from
well surprisingly entertainment may
provide a key
the organization define american studied
the television show superstore on nbc
it features a wide range of characters
including mateo
an undocumented immigrant
you grow to know and love him over the
course of the show
but eventually the narrative turns mateo
is taken by
ice for deportation
define american found that nearly half
of the people who watched this storyline
said they would take more pro-immigrant
related actions as a result
including advocating to family and
friends
that means the night this show aired
nearly 500
000 conversations across the u.s about
immigration took place
as a direct result of mateo's storyline
entertainment can fundamentally change
how we feel about other people
and lastly most powerfully of all
entertainment can actually impact what
we do
now one of the things we as americans do
or rather don't do
is register to donate our organs in the
event of a tragedy
there's over a hundred thousand
americans currently in need of a donated
organ
and yet less than half of the us
population is a registered organ donor
it's a politically sensitive issue
difficult to legally mandate
but without that requirement how can we
solve the issue
well should come as no surprise that
here again entertainment can provide a
key
the hollywood health and society
initiative at usc
did a study of four prominent tv shows
with organ donation story lines
csi new york numbers house and grey's
anatomy
they found viewers who are not
registered organ donors were more likely
to actively choose to become organ
donors
if the story line encouraged donation
that's a big deal and this change in
behavior isn't just
limited to organ donations
indian soap operas led to a reduction in
misogynistic preferences for sons
u.s medical dramas led to an increase in
breast cancer screening
and entertainment has even proven to
increase vaccination rates
so entertainment impacts what we think
about ourselves what we think about
others
and even what we do
it can even step in where public policy
makers are failing
but lastly i want to take a moment to
acknowledge what's at stake here
entertainment has the power to do a lot
of good
it also risks doing a lot of harm
the most infamous example of this is the
1915 film the birth of a nation
a racist film depicting the civil war
and reconstruction that directly led
to the resurgence of the kkk
there are more modern examples as well
color of change found that popular crime
shows directly led to a normalization of
racial injustice in this country
and the netflix show 13 reasons why has
been found to lead to a 30 percent spike
in teenage suicides following the
premiere
entertainment is beholden to the studios
and creatives who develop this content
there's a lot at stake if they get this
wrong
but they in turn are beholden to us
you and me the content consumers and how
we choose to spend our money
so what do i want you to take away from
this
well first i want you to recognize the
power entertainment has over
you whether you're a policy maker you're
in the industry or you just watch
netflix on a sunday night
i want you to ask yourself whether what
you're watching is reflecting the
realities of the world we live in
or better yet if it's pushing the
envelope and showing you a world to
aspire to
but most importantly of all i want you
to invest
in the power of entertainment for social
change
whether it's a direct investment in an
organization like color of change or
define american
or just an investment with the kinds of
films and tv
you choose to purchase and watch
entertainment is powerful we all want to
live in a world
with more women in stem more empathy for
immigrants more organ donors and yes
more brown girls on the big screen i
hope you'll join me in pushing towards
this goal
you